your family's from Ghana is that right
we have born in Ghana no I was born in
Detroit but I've I spied bug spent my
whole life going back and forth to Ghana
my mom's from there at her side the
family's there does your mom have like
sort of Ghana isms yeah like so my mom
is like she like went to school in
England but she still has like they're
still like this Diskin disconnect I
guess like like her nickname was lady
malaprop's
who's just malapropisms which are like
messing up phrases and some like that or
saying stuff wrong man stuff wrong yeah
so like she'd say stuff like you know
burden hand is worth one in the hand and
I'm like that's not a phrase that is of
any use yeah value yes this is equal
yeah she's like kid she'd be like Oh Sam
you have any clean panties like cuz she
would prefer to underwear as panties no
matter what there's like Oh seeing the
fog your panties and like mom please
that's humiliating actually humiliating
yeah but then I got used to it and you
start wearing panties yeah I mean to god
it seems like that's I always heard it's
a fascinating country and and there's I
know that I don't know it's always
seemed to me like that'd be an amazing
place it really is beautiful you should
I mean you should visit yeah I should go
to go should what if I went to Ghana
would you go with me
absolutely you would go so long too long
nice to go haven't been in a long time
it'd be weird if I was your ambassador
to Ghana
please let me explain ghana to you